un avance hacia la igualdad la
confederación brasileña de fútbol
anunció que la selección es masculina y
femenina recibirán el mismo salario y
primas
y género esto significa que no habrá más
brecha de género en términos de
remuneración entre hombres y mujeres
aceves istat la confederación brasileña
de fútbol trata con total igualdad a
hombres y mujeres absolutamente en ibi
comics y müller es una igualdad que
aplicará desde los juegos olímpicos de
tokio y en los próximos campeonatos
mundiales la medida había sido tomada
anteriormente en australia nueva zelanda
o noruega
el empoderamiento femenino también llega
a bolivia y lo hace con iniciativas como
ping delivery una empresa de reparto a
domicilio en la ciudad de cochabamba
compuesta exclusivamente por mujeres que
fue mi decisión ya que trabajar con
puros hombres era incómodo para mí
entonces de esa manera decidí abrir lo
que espn de libre para que las chicas y
ayudar también a las madres que no
tienen trabajo que nos ha afectado de la
pandemia puedan llevar un sustento hasta
su hogar la plantilla ya cuenta con 15
mujeres reconocibles en toda la ciudad
por una llamativa indumentaria rosa
fue escogida la primera presidenta en la
historia de eslovaquia susana caputo va
es todo un fenómeno en el centro y el
este de europa sorprendiendo con todo
tipo de iniciativas comprometidas como
este embotellado de miel que fue
cosechada en las colmenas de su jardín
presidencial el primero envasado de miel
propia fue un éxito la miel está
producida de forma casera en el palacio
y el jardín presidencial es un perfecto
y original regalo para otros presidentes
las colmenas fueron instaladas el 26 de
mayo dentro de la iniciativa del centro
de educación ambiental y ética cívica
city bis con el objetivo de conservar la
vida de las abejas
[Música]
el cob y 19 paralizó la educación en
prácticamente todo el mundo
las tecnologías abrieron una ventana
para poder continuar con el aprendizaje
pero muchos niños por falta de recursos
quedaron desconectados sin embargo en
ciudad de mexico el rinconcito de
esperanza una tienda de tortillas quiso
poner solución en la tortillería sabemos
todo yo empezamos a platicar y poco a
poco a ver oye tú cómo vas a pasar este
regreso a clases no pues yo ni siquiera
tengo esto o esto esto no entonces entre
los vecinos nos fuimos organizando para
poder apoyar con esta premisa decidieron
establecer un área de aprendizaje con
tutorías internet y televisión en un
verdadero esfuerzo comunitario
[Música]
volvieron las obras a la inacabada gran
mezquita de mosúl su construcción inició
hace más de 20 años y el final se ha ido
demorando durante siete años por el
conflicto entre irak y el estado
islámico pero finalmente con la empresa
japonesa jade exit con más de 500
trabajadores se espera terminar la que
es la mezquita más grande de mosúl
[Música]